to see you again there is a degree of
truth in that narrative isn't there I
mean it's certainly what happened in
Brecon the brexit party votes had they
been given to the conservative candidate
which you know and other times that
would have been their natural home would
have led to a Conservative MP being
returned to pollen at a time when you've
got the most Breck City Conservative
leader we've had in a while well it's
great to have a breast is he
conservative leader it's about time and
he's only been in post for a while so
he's talking a good talk but I've yet to
see whether he's going to deliver and I
think that what happened in Bracken I
mean I think this idea that the voters
who voted for the brexit Party and
naturally Conservative Party's voters I
mean if a conservative parties think
that there are against is not yet being
abated I mean a lot of the people who
voted for the breadstick party and
Bracken would have been Labour voters
actually and can we just remember the
circumstances of that by-election which
was it was first of all called because
somebody had been involved in an
expensive scandal the same Conservative
Party decided that that candidate should
be the best that could be offered to
Brecon back I mean you know this shows a
certain content to the voters before you
start there are a number of marginals
which look quite similar and to break
and yeah idea that there will be a
competition between conservative and
party of the left in which if the brexit
party stakes votes away from the
Conservatives and they're certainly
billing themselves as the party to
deliver brexit no they weren't
necessarily that which they have done in
the past of course but if you take those
votes you're actually making
brexit less likely no so we all know
that you could sit and have a
calculation about what might happen in
the general election it depends when
that general election might be called
which we don't yet know but I think
there's something peculiar and actually
really offensive about the idea that you
have a party that says okay brexit party
you can stand down now you know we've
now got a kind of Conservative Party
that's talking the good talk on brexit
if the brexit party didn't exist treasom
a would still be running the
Conservative Party it seems if you
remember the circumstances in which it
was born as a party brexit was more or
less the watered and / so you have to
say that the row
of the bracele party continues to be to
argue for a clean brexit to carry on
arguing for democracy and remember that
that Democratic mandate was about to be
thwarted brexit voters were being
introduced and delighted that Boris
Johnson's got a campaign team and a
cabinet made up of brexit supporters but
the idea that anyone treats the breaks
apart is a kind of jr. wing of the Tory
body that kind of can be dismissed
because we've done our job doesn't
understand that there's something much
more profound happening in British
politics today I do I do I take your
point but at the same time apparently
little 10 conservative MPs have
approached the brexit party and
suggested you know what guys it might be
a good idea if you do what you know
happened on the left or the center-left
and break and step aside and give us a
clear run so the point about and PacSun
give us a clear ride and it could be
said that one of the things that could
have happened in the Peterborough by
election was that the Conservative Party
could have stood aside and given the
brexit Party a clear ride because the
Tory party came nowhere in the piece of
Rabbi election and the brexit party came
a very close second what of course it
could I'm saying it depends on the
elections called but I also think can we
just move away from this idea that any
party owns brexit that includes a brexit
party by the way I think every single
party has thought I mean the Tory party
said you can't go around saying we're
the natural home of brexit I want them
to deliver the brexit party however does
appeal more often in the north and we've
just been talking you've just been
talking about the north and there are a
lot of people who lay believers you
would think very strong now before
voting for the Conservatives so what I'm
saying is is that it's more complicated
than simply being told to go away when
in fact the Tory party they've been
talking this talk for 10 days to 2 but
the brexit party has just been around
for it for a little longer than that I
mean you get yes you're being you've
mentioned several times though the
prospect of a general election later
this year if that happens what are the
policy platforms on which the brexit
party will be campaigning beyond bricks
at our course yeah so one of the things
that's been really nice about the very
limited
the kind of policy discussion put
forward by the brexit party I mean it's
not God knows it's not fully formed
manifesto was it did focus on saying
there has to be major infrastructure you
know Industrial changes in the north so
one of the things that you could say
that's what it announced way before it's
just been announced I mean it's it's
part of a recognition that comes out of
the whole vote for leave that there's
huge ways of the country that needs to
be developed you start handing medicine
on from from the Northland paralyze
partnership I mean where does the brexit
party support for the big infrastructure
spend it will get us closer to the
powerhouse ideal where does the money
come what is the brexit party's position
on it chance to well it nounce its
position it said cancel hs2 and have a
different kind of infrastructure or
growth in the north how are you gonna
pick up votes in the north advance your
position of cancelling a chess team well
first of all I haven't met very many
people who are in enthusiastically
cheering for a chess - one of the big
things is that there has to be much
better transport links but you know I
wanted to talk about the broader policy
issues which you've just asked me about
because I think that what the brexit
party has got going for it is that it
says politics should be done differently
and everywhere I've gone in the
northwest where I was campaigning people
say they're federal to party politics I
kind of whisk stock in a kind of one way
of doing it the brexit party could
hiring some very slick PR people develop
their policies in a the London office
and present them all very nicely but
it's argued it's argued it's argued that
it should be bottom up right and that I
think is very positive it isn't isn't
part of the reason that you don't have a
fully fleshed-out policy portfolio is
because as things stand the brexit party
is a collection of people with very
disparate political views after you've
moved from Marxism to kind of whatever
you are active libertarianism at the
moment you look at others within your
party I think they would struggle to
describe themselves and either of those
two week I agree so the big thing that
holds us together is is that a
commitment to democracy and believing in
the popular sovereignty and national
sovereignty which nobody else seems to
be bothered about and sell a few you
know and so recently so what we're
trying to do is to build a new kind of
politics that's what I think that people
don't understand if people say
oh all that the breadstick party should
be is some sort of like Tory like
version or should just kind of come up
with a new word politics done the same
away why can't you have a bottom-up
policy discussion we're going to have
national conversations we're actually
opening up the discussion guess what to
the voters what a shock that is and
there might be the possibility you know
that you could shake up politics because
one thing that has been revealed by the
brexit vote or rather the inability for
the mainstream parties and Parliament to
deliver it is that that what we've got
now is an opportunity to redo politics
people have seen the complete barrenness
and of it major institutions House of
Lords first-past-the-post not really
working and the media dare I say it
major institutions now off for question
lots of people are actually asking more
profound questions about what post
brexit Britain might look like so the
first job the brightest apart is make
sure breakfast delivered and if that
involves by the way electoral PACs that
might happen
maybe the touring party might instead of
telling the brexit point what to do make
an approach of the rectory part and so
what we tell you what will stand aside
in certain areas that would be a very
positive thing for me let's work
together new kind of politics I'm quite
excited you see any certainly seem it at
Claire Fox thanks for joining us on the
show